If you're on your way to Mars you can't exactly
turn around if your stomach hurts, or if you
cut your finger.
How DO we solve medical emergencies in space?
Hey gang, Trace here with your DNews Weekly
Space Update.
Astronauts are REALLY far from Emergency Rooms
and hospitals if a health crisis comes up.
As of now, only 24 people have left low-earth-orbit,
we've not spent much time away from the cradle
of humanity.
But, we are planning missions to Mars and
elsewhere in deep space, and we need to figure
this stuff out before we can go safely.
Of the around 540 people who have been to
space, most of the medical issues have been
due to space sickness, but there have incidence
of arrhythmia -- irregular heartbeat, renal
colics -- or kidney stones, and infections.
Luckily, no one has been TOO badly injured
yet.
Most injuries actually occur during takeoff
or landing.
Of those, the most common is a near-syncopal
episode due to orthostatic hypotension...
or passing out from low blood pressure.
Of course, all of this has been based on the
HISTORY of space travel; the FUTURE is going
to see a whole different set of issues.
Chronic illness, trauma, injury, and maybe
even unknown medical conditions, not to mention
the psychological strains!
According to a study from the University of
York in Canada, emergency incidents occur
at about 0.06 per person, per year in the
general population.
So, for a two-and-a-half year trip to Mars,
with seven crewmembers, the math says we WILL
HAVE one emergency.
Unfortunately, there's no way to know what
that emergency will be, so we'll just have
to prepare for everything.
The space shuttle would always have two crew
medical officers trained in first aid and
a Shuttle Orbiter Medical System to deal with
pre-planned issues.
The CMOs were trained in dealing with minor
illnesses and injuries.
They could give injections, provide medications
and antibiotics and even stitch their fellow
crewmember up!
On the International Space Station, the Routine
and Emergency Medical Operations Manual lists
what to do for scrapes, nausea, broken bones,
ulcers, infections, burns and even how to
handle space-based pregnancy tests.
They have the equipment to deal with it all,
but bleeding in space isn't the same as on
Earth.
Without gravity, blood droplets could float
into eyes, mouths and equipment and even small
arteries could spurt fluids.
As we venture deeper into space, surgery is
GOING to happen, and it could be a HUGE mess.
A neurosurgeon in Pittsburgh came up with
the idea of putting a fluid-filled dome over
an open, bleeding wound.
The water pressure and surface tension could
stem the bleeding until a surgeon could sew
it closed.
It's been built and will be put through a
final test on Virgin Galactic's SpaceShipTwo,
once it gets running.
But before you cut someone open, modern doctors
need to know what they're going to find in
there.
This month, A group of Stanford students tested
a portable ultrasound machine in microgravity
on the famed, "Vomit Comet," a special 747
that lets people simulate microgravity by
flying in a parabola.
The ultrasound works fine here on the ground,
but in space because of microgravity, things
behave differently.
This means they need to test it and alter
the design or parameters so it will work properly.
The lead student told Popular Science astronauts
will need everything we have on a ground-based
ER available to them in space.
And they'll need to make sure they all work
properly.
It's a big job.
There are other things being implemented and
tested in the years leading up to our deep
space missions.
They're testing communications uplinks, so
astronauts can confer with doctors on the
ground and medical devices to use in case
of everything they can think to plan for.
The portable ultrasound machine works great,
by the way, so hopefully they'll have that
one to check off the list.
Are you worried about hurting yourself in
space?
Tell us about it in the comments and maybe
we'll make an episode about it!
Thanks for watching DNews, subscribe for more.